à à
anh alo cho các bạn
Alo ạ
Xin chào bạn
Ừ để cha vẫn còn sớm nha
Ừ đợi tí nhé
ừ ừ
à à
các bạn kiểm gọi mình là đại ca
thật ra với mình gì đại ca mình từng kể
các bạn thấy đại ca của mình rồi
ngắm một chút Thế lại nhắc lại con người
đấy thì mình từng nói đại ca của mình nó
kiểu hơi bị trẻ trâu 1 tí anh ấy 96 anh
ấy Kiểu như mày ra dạ này nhưng mà vẫn
trẻ trâu Nghĩa là già dặn khi đừng nước
này và giờ dạng khi nói chuyện người
khác cần trẻ trâu khi ở cạnh mình kiểu
khi hai đứa chị điên cãi nhau kiểu cái
thế buộc Lộc hết bản chất ra cái ghế
Ừ thì Nhưng mà cái này của mình với anh
đấy ngoài việc kiến thức đẹp trai rồi
chỉ cho khác với việc à Anh đây khi mà
anh ấy đừng lớp anh đấy là một con người
khác hoàn toàn kiểu dạng là đương nhiên
là mình đứng lớp thì mình muốn người
khác Kiều
mình mình trẻ trâu thì mình sẽ hạn chế
hơn mình sẽ trở nên nghiêm túc mình
không văng tục mình không Mình không là
kiểu trở thành con người kéo nó gọi chín
chắn hơn nhớ anh đấy người đúng kiểu
khác hoàn toàn bởi vì à anh đấy và các
thầy các thầy ở trường cũ của mình dạy
bên quản trị mạng là bên bảo mật thông
tin chứ làm gọi gọi là hacker ấy toàn
mấy thầy Toàn hacker khét tiếng cả thì
mày thay đấy à xe điều hướng nội cả như
mình đã từng nói những người hướng nội
để ngoài việc là họ rất tốt trong việc
cậu
tự học rất tốt và kiểu Cái quan trọng là
họ không để cái á cảm xúc của mình bị
chi phối bị ảnh hưởng bị tác động bởi
bên ngoài
anh kể cái này thì nếu mà nói thẳng ra
thì nó là như kiểu dạng như ví dụ giả sử
như trong trường hợp của mình Mình thì
một người hướng ngoại Thành A có mình sẽ
bị chi phối bởi cảm xúc và sự là có ai
bây giờ đang bình luận được ạ lại văng
tục bạn chửi mình có khi mình sẽ cáo có
khi mình cũng sẽ hiểu bị mất ảnh hưởng
ảnh hưởng cái cảm xúc khi dạy hoặc là
lúc dậy mình có vấn đề gì đó Giả sử thế
họ trước khi dạy mình gần đây gì đó thì
mình sẽ rất dễ bị ảnh hưởng cảm xúc
có bạn thì sẽ cảm thấy hôm trước rủ Hôm
trước mình dậy nó có thể giọng hào hứng
hơn có về truyền cảm ứng hơn còn hôm sau
thì lại kiểu khác bởi vì mình cũng hay
bị ảnh hưởng bởi cảm xúc nhiều Mình vẫn
chưa sửa được rồi đấy chắc mình vẫn còn
non và trẻ quá Ừ thì à
những thầy kia những người người hướng
nội đấy họ hoàn toàn không để cho ai
biết được họ đang buồn mà em vui ạ Được
kiểu thế thành ra là khi họ lên zậy chắc
ai cũng biết họ đoàn hiểu thật sự như
thế nào chả thế họ vẫn pha trò họ vẫn
Kiều dậy như bình thường giọng họ vẫn
thế Rất khó để nhận ra được đủ ngoan thì
mình cảm thấy dân Lệ những người như thế
mà những người đấy mang tiếng hướng nội
nhưng vẫn nói nhiều ấy
không Mình đang ví dụ thế thôi chắc là
không có ông nào ở đây tự nhiên vào ném
đá mình thế đâu chơi đến lúc Nếu mà ở
Ừ nhưng mà cũng cũng có cứ điều đấy có
thể xảy ra giờ xử dạng như là về sau
mình cũng có ý định là hôm nay có bạn
hỏi hỏi hỏi mình đó là hết hóa học ở
khóa học của ép cơ bản này đã cả cả cái
khóa nâng cao ấy thì mình sẽ dậy gì cơ
sở thì mình đang nghĩa mình sẽ không dại
gì nữa mình định thế theo kiểu là
cũng tương đối đủ kiến thức để các bạn
có thể học từ một người khác rồi Gần như
thế còn kiến thức sau kiến thức kiểm
nâng cao có thử các bạn thực ra vẫn thể
hỏi mình Họ hỏi trên kênh dysport của
nhóm thực tế mình mở những cái nâng cao
ra ấy Dự lại ít người cần biết hoặc là
mình sẽ phải làm cái có khác
thì mình sẽ phải làm đi câu khác kiểu
kia thế thực ra có mình cũng mua một vài
khóa nâng cao của các đương nhiên các
thầy giáo nước ngoài của các chuyên gia
bên nước ngoài thì họ dạy nó mới chuẩn
hơn
cùng đám ma Chắc là chưa có người Việt
nào dạy cái đấy sẽ là mình sẽ mình sẽ
phải dạy lại hiểu phong cách kiểu tiếng
Việc kiểm dịch lại thôi Chứ gần như là
mình không thể chuyên được bằng những
lời người có nhiều năm kinh nghiệm như
kia rồi đúng không Nghĩa gần như ở kiến
thức của mình chỉ đủ cơ bản để mà dậy
cho các bạn là cách ổn nhất đi chứ còn
nâng cao của nó lại rất rộng để mà dậy
thì cũng như là mình cũng không bị là sẽ
dạy lại những cái mà mình đã dạy bởi vì
mình đã đăng hết lên kênh YouTube rồi
Đương nhiên những người đến sau mấy sẽ
thiệt thòi hơn là người không xem trực
tiếp được đóng ngoặc
hai người đã học trực tiếp họ cuốn hơn
các bạn là những khóa đầu tiên của mình
dạy Online đúng không ạ thì các bạn cũng
có tý may mắn đúng không ạ bởi vì mình
cũng muốn nói với anh Tuấn là nên mở lớp
và nên mở kênh discord mở ra để cho các
bạn bây giờ còn tranh thủ vào vốn học
online còn cảm thấy hào hứng chứ về sau
mà anh mới mở Anh ấy đang mở theo kiểu
là kiểu còn duyệt thành viên để cho nó
chất lượng ấy nhưng mà phía sau mới vào
thì các bạn đấy Sẽ thấy một đống khóa
học các bạn sẽ bị quá tải cũng như là
toàn là những cái video xem lại thì nên
là nó không khác gì nó không khác gì so
với mua khóa học online hay là xem trên
YouTube của người khác à
Vì mình thấy thực sự thì nếu mà không có
livestream tuyển ngay các bạn cũng sẽ
thấy chán hơn mà nó gọi
thế trên hết là các bạn bây giờ với các
bà cũng may mắn kiểu thế
anh may mắn ở được thứ nhất là đúng được
dịch này rất nhiều yếu tố đúng không
xong rồi Đây là những khóa đầu vân vân
kết hợp với được là
thực sự thì cái dạy Công Nghệ Thông Tin
dạy lập trình mà từ đầu quyền của như
thế này thì các bạn nếu mà cha ở trên
mạng ấy nó sẽ tương đối giá Không rẻ đâu
khi mà người da cầm tay chỉ lỗi các bạn
đến tận làm hạn đoán Không có chuyện đấy
đâu ạ
Ừ
đúng rồi còn nhiều bạn mình cảm thấy ví
dụ Giả sử bây giờ Nhóm thành phiên utyt
hơn 350.000 người và trong đó this code
có chị hơn 20.000 người Chứng tỏ là
20.000 người kia có gì đó Ngoài việc
kiểu tham gia cho vui ra thì cũng may
mắn hơn đúng không ạ
à à Ừ cái kiến thức này thì chắc trà mà
sẽ rất rộng thế nên là mình mới bảo là
các bạn chỉ nên theo về khóa cơ bản để
nó thực sự của thấy nó đủ nó đủ níu kéo
các bạn thế mà các bạn có thể tiếp tục
theo ngày này không
Bởi vì cơ bản là vậy thì nó là cơ bản
thế này ai hoàn toàn treo cũng được và
nó không nặng nề lắm Còn cái nâng cao
thì mới thể hiện sự rất nặng nề và giữa
kiểu các bạn làm nó nó giống như là kiểu
như này các bạn làm xong quạt các bạn
các bạn không thể theo đi thực tập được
khi các bạn đi được tập cũng sẽ không có
lương gì đến
Ê cái cơ bản Đấy nó sẽ chỉ dạy các bạn
vì cái nền thôi nhớ các bạn kheo được
xong khóa nâng cao mình khẳng định luôn
là các bạn có thể đi vàng khoe luôn cả
đồ án mà làm xong cho cái khóa nâng cao
đấy các bạn có thể
gọi là đi của nghĩa là kiểu thương lượng
với cái mức lương có thể lên đến 78
triệu được rồi cái này mình khẳng định
được mình mình khẳng định được điều đấy
Đúng nghe cờ mình không Chém gió đi cả
các bạn hoàn toàn là xong được khóa nâng
cao các bạn bảy tám triệu mức lương khởi
đầu chưa cần có kinh nghiệm cái các bạn
vẫn thể làm được thì họ sẽ thấy để nó là
cái
ở ranh giới giữa việc một người gặp đi
thực tập toán khó với một người có thể
vào được làm được việc luôn nó sẽ khác
biệt như thế nào thì nên là ở Cái khóa
đấy mới khóa quyết định chứ Còn bây giờ
thì các bạn nói với mình là giống như
sinh viên mình mình thấy bảo sinh viên
Đó là em nỡ bỏ tiền là học rồi Ở đây các
bạn không trả tiền các bạn bỏ thời gian
thôi cũng quý nhưng ý là bỏ bỏ ra rồi
đúng không ạ thì các bạn cũng phải theo
đến một cái ngưỡng là lấy để các bạn mới
có thể khẳng định được là các bạn có phù
hợp với nói không Các bạn có thích nói
không các bạn không thể làm à kiểu mới
học thấy kho thôi bỏ qua cái thế thì
chẳng có con đường nào dễ dàng cả đúng
ngoan ạ
A và trừ khi các bạn từng kiểu tiếp xúc
nó chán chê rồi thì các bạn mới có thể
nhận xét từ những điều đấy không ạ Mày
có thể khẳng định được nó hợp với mình
hay không
ừ ừ
à
Còn kênh livestream này về sau mình thì
chắc là mình sẽ như anh Tuấn có đề xuất
mà về sau mình có thể là kiểu thỉnh
thoảng sẽ có thể ra mùi khóa không hoàn
khóa rồi chỉ là một cái playlist một cái
danh sách một cái kiểu gần ngựa
livestream để mà cốt ra được một cái gì
đó giống như là anh Tuấn thì mình cũng
mới đề xuất hại vì anh Tuấn đó là anh
Tuấn thực ra chuyện này bên là mà cả về
tiện ích gần như tiện lấy chưa thích sẽ
coi tinh gián đoạn biết rồi thì anh Tuấn
có thể livestream để mà kiểu cốt từ đầu
đến cuối một cái tiện ích ở đó để các
bạn thể xem tham khảo đương nhiên cốt
nhưng xem được cả cốt tất cả mọi thứ
công khai hết mình vì sao mình sẽ định
làm như thế mình sẽ livestream để mà cốt
cái có thể trang web gái xinh của mình
Họ vẫn Thiện ích cái sinh của mình Ừ
cũng được thực sự thì livestream cốt đấy
nó cũng sẽ hơi bị nhằm chán tí kết hợp
với việc là
ờ có nhiều người chúng ta cố còn tỏ mình
nhưng mà các bạn vào thì ngoài để mà
em chẳng học hỏi một phần thôi Quan
trọng là kiểu nhìn cách mà người ta giải
quyết vấn đề ở đó ngoại cũng như trò
chuyện vui thôi kiểu gì thế
anh em
Ừ
mai cốt như thế nhưng mà ạ đúng đúng nó
có thể học hỏi được rất nhiều với những
người mới có những người đã đi làm rồi
rồi là người ta không có nhiều thời gian
để mà xem cái đấy mà mình lại livestream
đúng cái mà nó sẽ Ví dụ mình sẽ
livestream dùng level nghĩa là cường
quốc rồi là cái ngôn ngữ lập trình bậc
cao dồi kiểu gì thế đấy thì nó lằn nâng
cao chứ không còn là cơ bản nên là cạnh
những đối tượng cơ bản cần học thì lại
không học được nhiều từ đấy còn những
người hiểu được cái đấy thì sửa thực sự
người ta không có thời gian để xem về
đưa Hương Xưa tại yếu tố nó như thế thế
nên là bây giờ mì ít người livestream
kiểu cốt hoặc là người ta chuyển hướng
sang là chỉ dạy những cái rất là cơ bản
về các bạn trai trên mạng cô dạy lập
trình cơ bản nhiều lắm cả nước ngoài cả
việc điển hình với anh ấn độ đấy ạ
Ừ đúng rồi thì các bạn mà theo từ đầu
đến cuối một cái sản phẩm gì đó các bạn
sẽ dễ hình dung hơn
ừ ừ
các bạn vịt con bạn ấy nói qua về cái vụ
lập trình đôi cả
ạ Mình chẳng biết mình kể các bạn với vụ
lập trình đâu chưa
Vì sao nó lại nghỉ thì tên bạn đấy là vì
con đã càng rất phù hợp tính khái niệm
lập trình đôi đúng không ạ
họ lập trình đôi nó repairing này Đúng
Nghĩa là nó có đòi hỏi nhưng mà Cái quan
trọng là cái
yêu cầu đây nó đã hành đo hỏi là hai
người cùng phải có cùng trình độ để mà
lập trình Cùng nhau mỗi người sẽ cốt
chưa cậu một nửa một nửa kiểu một người
khuất 30 phút người người kia sẽ ngồi
xem người đưa cốt sau đó thì lại đổi đổi
vai như thế chỉ một màn hình một bàn
phím cơ thế đấy thì hoàn toàn là cái
kiểu Làm lập trình kiểu ngày chưa ra
tương đối nhanh nhờ việc thứ ra lập
trình thì khi mà các bạn để lấy ngưỡng
nào đó thì ai cũng sẽ biết cốt Nhưng
quan trọng là việc mà tối như cốt cũng
như
tìm được bất cách tìm được lỗi thì ra là
tốn nhiều thời gian tốn đến 80 phần trăm
thời gian thì ra là
chỉ cần có một người luôn xem việc ạ Các
bạn đang cốt có đúng hay không Vân Vân
đóng ngoặc thì cái mình đang định nói là
lập trình đôi này nhưng mà đôi khi các
bạn không có ai ngồi Làm lập trình cùng
thì sẽ có lập trình con vịt cao su
em nè
Ừ cái kỹ tặng kỹ thuật đi Bắc đỉnh cao
nó rapper đất kia nó sẽ dùng con vịt cao
su
em ngồi đấy để mà
đêm hả Kiều bạn sẽ ngồi Giải thích từng
dòng cốt cho con vịt cao su này cốt là
thời ra là gần như bạn đang nói chuyện
với chính mình tự giải thích cốt để
chứng minh để tự mình gọi là sẽ lại cốt
thì
Mà tại sao nó còn vịt cao su mới kìa con
vịt cao su nó dễ bóp thì bạn ức chế cái
gì đó chế tạo sẽ bóp nhau và kết hợp
việc là hồi trước ở từng có cái kiểu là
dùng gương ở bên cạnh mình để mà mình
vừa
vừa cầu giải thích cốt vừa nói chuyện
với mình trong gương ấy Nhưng mà thực ra
mấy ông sẽ mất tập trung với ông mẹ mày
lắm cái gương quá nên thôi tốt nhất là
nó sinh ra cái trò này
Ừ
cái việc một người nói chuyện một mình
nó có thể hơi bị điên khi mà nhìn trong
con mắt người khác nhưng mà nếu mà người
cũng không giải quyết được mất không về
quyết được vấn đề Tôi khẳng định là
người ấy còn điên hơn khi nói chuyện với
người khác thế nên là mấy ông quen dần
việc ấy hãy đừng kỳ thị nó mà hãy chuẩn
bị nghĩ rằng là mình sắp như thế vào
mình phải tìm giải pháp như thế nào Ví
dụ điển hình điển hình nhất nhé đó là
kiểu rất nhiều lúc mình các bạn đấy Mấy
lần nhắn tin mình thế mà mình quen rồi
đó là đó là kiểu mình hỏi ai đó cậu Anh
ơi em có vấn đề này xong rồi Lúc mà mình
giải thích câu hỏi là tự nhiên mình này
ra được cách giải quyết vấn đề thì bản
chất là mình đang giải thích cốt tự
chính mình thôi đúng không
Ô kìa
Thì cái này nó chẳng điên thì đã nó giữa
bình thường ở trong cái ngành này đó não
mình có thể chưa tải được xong rồi vấn
đề đấy não mình vẫn đang xử lý
Ừ cái này lại đảo liên quan đến bài toán
về tâm lý một tí hồi trước không phải
tâm lý mà nó về cái cách thức xử lý của
hệ thần kinh mình kiểu mới ở tôi Giả sử
Cho hỏi ông một cái bài toán đó sau đó
thì tôi chưa kịp cho ông trả lời câu đấy
cứ sự là 100 cộng 200 bằng bao nhiêu
chẳng hạn đó tôi không xong rồi tôi gạt
đi luôn tôi không cho ông trả lời rồi
nữa thì não ông ông sẽ nghĩ ra là não sẽ
nhờ xanh đấy chủ đề khác luôn mà không
hề xử lý cái bài toán vừa rồi chưa có
không não ông bạn tiếp nhận thông tin và
vẫn sẽ xử lý và toàn đấy và nó sẽ lưu
tạm vào trong bộ nhớ của não điều gì thế
bà khi mà ông nhắc lại cái bài giòn đấy
não vẫn sẽ bật ra ngay thì ko trả lời
chứ không cần mất công tính toán loại
nữa Trông chờ ở mấy ông chưa đọc rồi đấy
nhưng mà cái đấy nó mới thể hiện rõ là
não mình giống như máy tính thôi nào
mình thể xử lý nhiều thứ cùng một lúc
cũng như là
I kiểu nó vẫn cần có thời gian để xử lý
nhưng hàng ra kìa các bạn không thể nghĩ
rằng cái này khó rồi các bạn sẽ bỏ qua
được làm như thế làm sẽ làm mất cái mạch
Đang xử lý của não thế nên là các bạn
vẫn phải để não nó tự phát một lúc thậm
chí là lót vài ngày rồi để ra được vấn
đề đó thế
Ừ nhưng mà đương nhiên thì có người kiểu
dạng mà không thể các bạn bắt một cái
thằng học sinh tiểu học đó làm bài toán
đại học rồi bảo mày nghĩ nửa năm đi chắc
là nó sẽ ra đấy không như thế nào nó lại
bị chết gửi trái giờ hết đó ngọn gió máy
tính cùi không ở bắt nó làm những cái
việc khó vội đúng ạ Nhưng cái máy tính
này nó có thể
nó có thể tự nâng cấp nó được Nó là kiểu
ấy hay mà nó học máy tự thì học gọi đây
là các bạn phải nâng trình Hóa lên lại
làm từ cái dễ trước nhân dân với cái khó
Cái này thì ra thế này các bạn thấy hiển
nhiên nó đúng rồi nhưng mình đã nói nó
như thế nó kiểu não hoạt động nó như thế
cho nên các bạn không thấy nó khó quá
thì các bạn cứ đi từ dễ trước cứ dần dần
dần
300 nên thấy khó quá bỏ qua không ạ
anh em giải thích cốt cho người yêu vài
tháng sau này chia tay em luôn ông giải
thích kiểu gì cháu giải thích cậu làm
cho não lại theo miui loại bỏ tôi giải
thích cốt từ trước này thì ra đây cũng
là một trong những cái mà
gọi như là nhỉ ờ dân công nghệ thông tin
nhiều ông bảo với tôi là kiểu Tán gái
khó Thôi cậu em em chỗ khó khăn em nói
chuyện với cốt nó chán mấy ông nói kiểu
gì Nếu không chỉ ở những cái thứ hai họ
giống như tôi hay chỉ với ông này đúng
không ạ Tôi chỉ cơ thể từ trước nay tôi
thấy kiểu cho toàn gái bằng cái công
nghệ công ty đi tôi có tôi nhiều lúc tôi
muốn hẹn hò tôi phát thì máy tính thôi
đi tôi giải thích cốt cho nó cơ không
phải cốt nhưng mà kiểu để nó cốt cho nó
xem một đoạn thì đói nó sẽ càng thể yêu
ai anh ngày ngồi anh ấy Siêu vãi cả tư
đấy nó sẽ mắt nó sáng lên giống như kiểu
tưởng nhìn thấy tiền trả chứ Đấy thì ý
nghĩa là mấy ông hoàn toàn có thể
em có cái góc nhìn khác và có thể làm
mọi thứ nó khác đi mà tại mấy ông kia
làm cho
làm cho mấy bị choáng mà mấy em lấy và
mấy ông cũng không
không biết cách phải mà làm cho nó trở
nên thú vị hơn đấy thì chết
khi bé lỗi của mấy ông không phải lỗi
cho nhà ngay sự như thế
em vẫn nghe vụ 2 tỷ vua mỗi ngày chưa
không phải liên quan bị tiền đâu nhé mà
chẳng qua là cái giỏi sẽ làm được thôi à
anh ạ
hai cây thôi hơn 8 giờ rồi tạo quay lại
bài học nhé khi
Cho mình xin hãy trả lời những câu hỏi ở
đây nhá ạ
cho con sớm thì làm mấy triệu phân tích
web abc.xyz sử dụng công sử dụng gì mặc
bộ kaki nam thì thực ra thì cái có cái
tiện ích để mà biết được đón xem web sử
dụng gì nhưng mà cứ tiện ích kể chuyện
mức tương đối thôi
Nếu mà quét nổi tiếng thì may ra các bạn
có thể tra Google luôn việc web với sử
dụng công nghệ gì
nhưng mà còn phải bố cục thì bố cục thì
chắc là mình nghĩ là mình không Hoặc là
chuyên đều aos lắm đây là mình xin phép
không nhận xét về bố cục ở đây lắm nhờ
các bạn nhưng mà cái này Tại sao tự
nhiên mình để lại câu hỏi đây khi mình
không trả lời được không phải để mình
nói cái câu mình không xài được mà mình
sẽ nói theo kiểu như này tao ra thì các
bạn là bây giờ chính vì các bạn nó tham
ăn ngày đúng ạ Các bạn nên thường xuyên
thắc mắc khi mà vào một cái phần mềm màu
đó một cái Trang web nào đó như này đúng
không kể cả trên điện thoại trên máy
tính gì gì đó các bạn Bỉ kỹ xem Tại sao
tại sao nó lại có những cái nút như thế
Tại sao nút này là để đây Tại sao nút
lại màu này vẫn rơi thứ nút này Tại sao
to này Vân Vân các bạn sẽ hiểu dần về
cái kiểu thực sự là cái trang web đầy nó
đang hướng đến cái kiểu gì xa sử dạng ưa
các bạn vào Facebook em ạ Các bạn thấy
đây ra sự đây trang Facebook này Ừ mình
đang mở Facebook tí mình có lý do nó bây
giờ sử trang Facebook này các bạn thấy
thực sự thì cái phần nào nó đang là to
nhất ở trên màn hình đúng không ạ Cái
phần nào ra to nhất trên màn hình cái
nào nó chiếm ở chỗ trọng tâm đúng ạ Cái
chỗ nào nó đang ẩn đi phải bấm vào mấy
click thì nó mới hiển thị ra nó đóng
ngoặc thì các bạn sẽ dần dần nhận ra cái
đấy nó không quan trọng và cái kia Cái
quan trọng đóng ngoặc là sử là Facebook
này nó luôn hướng về cái trang cái kẹo
cái bài đăng tin tức nên nó luôn cho nó
giữa trung tâm bà chiếm nhiều không gian
diện tích nhất đúng không có những cái
tùy những cái kiểu những cái phím tắt
thì sẽ luôn để làm bên trái hoặc à Ở
trên đúng không những cảnh quy trình thì
nó sẽ nằm ở bên phải Và phải cần ấn mấy
cái click thì nó mới ra đời các quy
trình đấy vì ít người bấm động hoặc tìm
kiếm thấy nó sẽ kiểu nó nằm ở trên bởi
thường là người dùng đi tìm kiếm luôn có
xu hướng là bấm lên trên để tìm thanh
tìm kiếm kiểu kiểu như thế thì họ sẽ
thấy dần với cái bố cục của một cái
trang web hoặc một phần mềm bất kì Nó sẽ
phải có những cái quy tắc nhất định
và nó phải hướng vậy Cái gì nữa ra xử
giống như cái trang để nhảy sang đấy
Google sheet này đúng không Hãy sao các
bạn thấy không còn là để thanh tìm kiếm
nữa đúng không cái thành Tìm kiếm bay
mất sợ đâu rồi đúng không Tại sao cái
cái đập mắt các bạn giờ chỉ còn những ô
đúng hoặc bởi vì em mình lên đây mình
làm việc với ô đơn giản ấy xấu đúng
không đấy các bạn thực sự ở các bạn vẫn
đang có cái suy nghĩ vẫn còn đang bị ảnh
hưởng suy nghĩ của người dùng thôi các
bạn đây là phải suy nghĩ của một người
dân công nghệ để xem là và thực sự mình
giống như hôm trước mình có làm mình có
chia sẻ các bài phân tích về cái á do
diện của thằng Google Map về Apple Maps
Nếu Ừ thế bạn có thể lên của chính thành
đối thủ của những cái thằng này để xem
giống như là thằng Twitter rồi nó sẽ
khác gì lòng Facebook đúng không hoạt
hình Google assistant này sẽ khác gì với
hàm excel của thằng mai có số của ngoan
các bạn sẽ thấy nó sẽ khác nhau khá
nhiều đấy đúng
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ hoàn toàn là
anh cảm thấy nó hay mà thú vị
từng cái chi tiết nhỏ một đấy sẽ cảm
thấy kiểu mình ngồi lòi hơn mấy cái ông
không Mày học Dân công nghệ kiểu như thế
à
ờ ờ tiếp theo bố cục của một web bán
hàng đó ngoại thì thực ra thì
ờ ờ
ý bạn này chắc là đang nói về cái việc
bố cục thì mình thấy nó đang phổ biến
quán ở đại tràng gần như à Lúc nào nào
giống nhau rồi còn nếu các bạn ấy đang
hỏi về cái giao diện của một cái bán
hàng đẹp thì ra các bạn Thể tra theo
khái niệm là terrorblade
xong ngồi hiện chữ quy nữa
này sự ra rất nhiều
hoặc à hoặc và về sau khóa khóa nâng cao
thì mình mới dậy các bạn đi ăn cắp ra
diện để mà sửa về theo ý mình kiểu như
thế còn khóa cơ bản này thì mình vẫn
mong các bạn code HTML sẽ tự mình cốt để
các bạn nhớ lại vì kiến thức chứ Bây giờ
các bạn đã học cách đi chôn nữa Vì sao
các bạn quyền sư mát hlcf Nó là cái gì
tiếp theo mình sẽ không dạy các bạn cặp
cắt giao diện hay à Về Photoshop các thứ
thứ vì mình bảo rồi mình không chuyên về
bên Thẩm mỹ lãm và mình cũng không hư đi
theo bên giao diện sẽ bỏ qua vụ này
không ạ ạ
ờ ờ
à Hôm trước mình có nói nếu các bạn còn
nhớ thì thì
elife cái
cái nhúng xé đóng ngoặc elight sẽ lớn
hơn thằng internal nó sẽ được ưu tiên
hơn nàng internal và còn đi tiên hơn cả
thằng đấy eli Đúng mình mở lại kỳ lạ này
Tân An internal này và
external hoặc là như này nhưng mà cái
này thì ra là nó nó chỉ là một mức tương
đối tương đối thôi Thì ra là không chính
xác lắm Tại sao bởi vì à sẽ có trường
hợp mà Thảo gần hơn sẽ ghi đè hơn đương
nhiên like cái xá gần nhất rồi Gần như ở
thế nhé Còn hôm trước các bạn nhớ về vụ
internal vẫn bị ghi đè và external của
hàng ngày khai báo trước sau đó thì lại
như mới nhú này khi thay nó vẫn đi đẻ
được này bé một trường hợp và còn thêm
trường hợp nữa giờ sư đó ở đây mình chủ
đề cập thêm cả Nếu giả sử các bạn muốn
ghi đè lên mọi thằng khác các bạn không
quan tâm cốt đang bị nhúng mở cái chỗ
nào các bạn muốn ghi đè mọi thằng khác
các bạn Thể Thêm chữ chấm than
importance ở sau về đoạn đấy đây mình sẽ
thử demo luôn các bạn cho nhanh nhỉ thì
có bạn sẽ thấy em nó sẽ ghi đè lên tất
cả những hàng khác không phân biệt like
gì gì đó nhưng tự nhiên nó vẫn có bị tắc
của nó đó là giờ sự tất cả các chỗ đều
dùng Inverter thì đương nhiên là thằng
Like nó vẫn sẽ là lên trên đúng không
Hãy kiểu thế thì mình chạy thử cái cô
hôm trước nhé
ừ ừ
ở đây giả sử như thế này các bạn sẽ thấy
là
ở đời cô hôm trước ở đây và
Ừ mình đang không nhúng cái gì cả đúng
không ạ sử đây internal này và dưới này
của mình sẽ lại like đúng không xử lý
được mình cho một cái đít Clash trên này
mình sẽ cho nó 1 cái màu gì đó màu có
màu đen đi
a style
background-color Black đi
vợ sẽ thấy nó đổi sang màu đen bởi vì I
like nó hơn đóng ngoặc thì thì
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ cho cái thằng inter
này flash trên
phải trên nóc
phải trên đây thì mình sẽ thêm cái
importance đ
sau đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy một tuần nó
sẽ được
sẽ được ưu tiên hơn đơn giản đấy thôi đó
đi
a tiếp theo là
cho
nên là làm hết trong một file hay chia
ra thành nhiều file kiểu hlcs Speech Thế
có bạn hỏi và có bạn trả lời luôn ở chỗ
bình luận rồi nhưng mà mình muốn trả lời
lại ở đây cho các bạn này không để ý đó
là thật ta ở những cái dự án lớn thì nó
như người ta sẽ tách là tùy từng trường
hợp là kiểu Bất Đắc Dĩ do kiểu là đây là
sự bạn có nhúng hết toàn bộ file
external Ở trên cùng và trên cùng nhé
Đúng à Sau đó thì nhưng mà trong Cài
file đấy có cái class này tự nhiên màu
nó sẽ sang một màu khác các bạn muốn
chỉnh lại cái class đấy sang một màu gì
đó đổi màu đó nó nhưng mà vẫn không muốn
sửa và file chính ở file chính em phải
này lại được rất nhiều file khác dùng
thì các bạn đương nhiên có thể sửa lại
like đúng không elai hỏi internal Cường
Thế còn không thì chủ yếu các bạn sẽ
tách Ở ngoài
ờ cái này thì
À hôm trước của bạn hỏi với mình đó là
em muốn làm trang web để sao cho mà ấn
cân cho new hoặc à cõi suốt có bạn nào
không để ý Đôi khi mình có thể hoàn toàn
gõ view chuộc ở trên chính điện thoại
nhá Chẳng qua là có mà không cần chân UV
trên điện thoại thôi nếu bạn hoàn toàn
gõ chữ view xuống đây này vào một cái
đường dẫn bất kỳ ở bằng chính điện thoại
các bạn sẽ xem được suốt ngày bất ngờ
đấy thì
Cho xem xổ chuộc như này thì sẽ anh xem
hoàn toàn được cốt các bạn hl sẽ ra
Swift đó ngoan thì có bạn kiểu
không muốn cho gác xem cái này thì giống
nhưng Phước mũi thì các bạn sẽ thấy là
cậu ngay Cốt nó sẽ cổ làm đứt như không
thể gọi chuyện không xem được nhưng Cốt
nó sẽ làm rất là rối đây kết hợp với
việc là cái đoạn này thì nó chuyển bằng
ghe Swift và Speed nó còn kiểu mã hóa
rồi Rất khó để đọc
xé thì nó nhúng ứa tràn lan kiểu như thế
toàn bộ HTML này vẫn sẽ được tạo ra bằng
g-suite sẽ gọi lên server lấy HCl về
nhưng mà giờ sự trong trường hợp thần
view chuột không được các bạn có thể ấn
á
bí ẩn cảnh ân ái inspect Xong rồi Các
bạn có thể xem ở đây này thì các bạn sẽ
thấy là class của nó vẫn sẽ được mã hóa
một phần nào đó và Xem cốt kiểu ngày
thực ra nó vẫn sẽ hơi khó chịu một tí vì
nó sẽ không có dấu cách các thứ thứ gì
cả vân vân vân đương nhiên là mình không
nói vụ là có rất nhiều cái bây giờ nó hỗ
trợ cả giải giải mã có cái thì hỗ trợ mã
hóa thì cũng phải có cái hỗ trợ giải mã
đúng nhưng mà ngờ Nhưng mà Đấy nói chung
ở mình thì mình
cảm thấy là thức là không không quan
trọng lắm mày được cả bọn nó thể biết
được htl và sẽ ra speak của mình B chủ
yếu về xong mình sẽ cốc hết mà ở bác em
thì những ngày đấy mình mới phải những
cái cần phải ẩn đi để cho thằng kia
không biết được cái thứ mình đang dùng
công nghệ Mình không dùng à
anh
nói trả lời tóm lại cái câu vừa rồi đó
là như mình đã từng khẳng định mua khi
mà người kia tải được về để mà nhìn thấy
được
Anh nhìn thấy được cái kiểu hiển thị
trên màn hình này ra người ta có rất
nhiều cách để mở lời nó các bạn không để
ẩn đi được cái thứ mà các bạn ẩn ở đi
thật toán nhưng mà Hiển thị nó ra như
thế nào thì cái đấy không thể biết được
ngoài bạn cầm cái đấy thì các bạn Thể ẩn
đi được thế thôi
ờ ờ những thứ mình sẽ chia sẻ Chắc là để
cuối buổi đi bây giờ tự nhiên lại hơi bị
nhiều thứ giám của tôi anh cái này thì
mấy ông nhớ Nhắc tôi nhé
ạ Bây giờ thì mình xin phép là chữa bài
hôm trước
mà hôm trước và theo theo như các bạn nó
muốn chữa Bay uống trước sẽ dùng posen
Loan à
vì hoàn cảnh à
ở đây thì à
từ hôm nay tôi sẽ chỉ chữa cái bôi sơn
nữa nhé Còn mấy cái cậu về cái này chắc
là mấy ông nắm rõ rồi tôi sẽ chỉ chữa
cho mày Ông Mười mấy cái ảnh này cho nó
nhanh thôi nhưng trước khi mà để mà làm
cái vụ này tôi sẽ phải dạy qua công thế
nào Bố xin nó sẽ có bao nhiêu loại posen
nữa thì tôi sẽ mở cái file demo khác xa
a
xe tải
cô bé giả sử là mình sẽ có
mình sẽ có như sau sẽ có 3 loại phu
Jason các bạn cần phải nhớ nó ghi lê
tiếp và appsolute
ra mình không nhớ viết có đúng hay không
nhưng Tâm tính nó cứ ý mình mà và Futsal
cái này dễ dẫn nhiều nhất mình dễ viết
về cái này dễ nhớ nhất thì mình sẽ nói
qua luôn thật sự bây giờ mình cho cái
body của mình sẽ rất là dài được xử thế
tại như này
body cách để và các bạn kiểu thay vì
phải bật ID cho cái body các bạn muốn
kiểu họ đền tên hệ luôn thì các bạn sẽ
không có gì đằng trước là sẽ chuyển tên
của thẻ thôi nó sẽ kiểu như này không
cần phải Thăng không còn dấu chấm đi cả
à Có đi mình sẽ cho nó chiều cao Nó là
2.000 hết đi tại sao như thế để mình có
thể kéo xuống như này đúng không chị đã
sửa mình có cái chữ Hello ở đây H1
Hello ở đây đã trồng hoa
đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy kéo xuống đi mất
chữ Hello đúng không ạ Nếu mà giờ xử là
trong trường hợp này mình muốn cái chữ
Hello nó sẽ đi cùng mình mã mình kéo
xuống nó vẫn hiển thị chữ Hero đúng ở
góc đấy thì mình làm như thế nào thì đây
chỉnh nữa ạ mua sườn là appsolute điều
mà mình sẽ Style nó là cuối sân a nhập
speak speak speak là phi sẽ hiểu đó cứng
là năm nhiều chỗ
đó các bạn sẽ thấy bên mình kéo lên kéo
xuống đây
đây mình sẽ để cho bé thẻ hát hay đấy và
heo chẳng ạ kết quả sẽ thấy sự khác biệt
và các bạn sẽ thấy là thằng heo này nó
không bị ảnh hưởng tí gì với thằng Hello
vì nó độc lập 12 tháng độc lập nhau
thằng H1 nó sẽ không dính vào cái hàng
ba đi nữa
áo kiểu dạy là nó không chiếm cái khoảng
khoảng trống ở đây thành ra thằng Heo nó
nằm ở đây Nếu là sự Xóa cái này đi này
Xóa đi Này các bạn sẽ thấy là Hello Xong
rồi nó sẽ đẩy cái thằng heo xuống với
thằng Hello này chiếm hết cả ngày vùng
mấy rồi và nó còn có kiểu nó làm bệnh
Xuống ấy nó giống em biết đấy nó sẽ đẩy
thằng kia xuống thêm một B Đồ ngoại thì
bây giờ như thế này nó sẽ
11 sai kiểu dạng mà không không chiếm
khoảng khoảng với cả thằng Hae rồi sẽ
nằm ở đây đúng không ạ
à à
Ừ thì bây giờ cái này thì chỉ có bạn áp
dụng ở đâu các bạn ấy thường hay rất
thấy ở những cái trang dụ để hình lại
Facebook thôi Khi mà mình kéo xuống thế
này thì những cái gì ra theo mình cái
thông báo này cái nút để mở ngoặc cái
xanh trên thanh địa chỉ đã hoặc cả các
bạn và một cái trang web bất kỳ thường
sẽ hiển thị kiểu chat với tôi này cứ Hoa
còn một đống quảng cáo và sẽ đi theo bạn
đến cuối chân trời nóng quá thì thì các
posen của nó sẽ thích Nhã nó sẽ ở Yên ở
chỗ đấy và các bạn nữa để đâu sẽ thấy đủ
ngon Nó khắp mọi nơi thì
A
và các bạn có thể chỉ cho nó thật sự các
bạn muốn chụp nó chui xuống dưới này
đúng không Mình sẽ bóp tâm
là không Chẳng ạ
đó bạn sẽ nhảy xuống dưới và các bạn có
thể cho nó sang bên này đúng không có
thể ra à Không
thì nó sẽ lại chui xong rồi đấy
các bạn có thể là kiểu chỉnh led Xong
rồi đến 1000 cái được cũng được tùy nóng
hoặc
là cái này có thể âm nhá Cái này có lợi
âm nhưng mà âm thì không biết là bao
nhiêu thôi à
a tiếp theo là của Rin về à
Ừ cái mình không nhớ chính xác về cái
khái niệm video tiếp vào chữ lắm nhưng
mà thầy mình thường dậy như thế này
không biết nó đúng hay không
thì
bạn thực sự là mình chỉ áp dụng thường
xuyên là nó là như thế này thôi
ở đó là mê tít thì các bạn luôn nhiều nó
thằng cha rồi mình thằng áp út nó sẽ
thằng con trong trường hợp nào mà tự
nhiên liên quan đến cha con nữa đây đó
trong trường hợp giờ sự như như cái hình
này các bạn hoàn toàn hệ gán cho giờ sự
cái đi trên này các bạn gái đi chơi nữa
không Không ngồi trên này thì cả cái
khung trên này nó sẽ hàng cha chẳng ạ
thằng cái ảnh này nó sẽ làm con thằng
con của thằng cha ấy sau đó thì mình sẽ
chỉ cho thằng này nó nằm trong hành tra
ở vị trí bao nhiêu Việt bao nhiêu đấy
nóng truyền mỏ neo được ngoạn đấy nghĩa
là mình
3 Season exilis nó sẽ nó sẽ là vị trí bộ
A như thế nào so với hàng Khuê tiếp tốt
là sao đây mình sẽ có ví dụ luôn cho bạn
dễ Hiệp
đi ra xương bị cho thằng Anna Style
personal qualities này
các bạn thấy thời gian nó vẫn ở đấy
không ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ là cái đồ heo
con gì nhỉ
Khi đãi cả nhà và lần này mình sẽ là
đương nhiên để mà làm việc và thằng
Trang con với những ngày phải là phần
con hàng này nó ngoan mình xin phép để
đổi lại cái này đi đi
Ừ cái gì này
ừ ừ
cả
hai sẽ thằng con này bà sau này sẽ là
appsolute này
lại chuyện nha các bạn sẽ thấy ra à Hai
thằng nó đang đẩy nhau chẳng chẳng ảnh
hưởng gì cả ngồi ở bây giờ mình sẽ cho
ví dụ Giả sử là thằng này sẽ nằm ở bên
phải đi
á không vi phạm được giữ cho - 200ah
có
chứa 200 nó 300 kia vậy lại đúng rồi
đúng rồi đấy
à à có phải như này
- 100 rồi nhá cho nhìn mức 50 50 với
cường độ rồi
ở
tại tại do thằng này các bạn nhớ mình
bảo là cái đít nó sẽ là đây cho bạn xem
Ừ cái đít đấy nó sẽ chiếm ở một cái góp
thì
nó sẽ chiếm lại các bạn nhìn khi mà trỏ
vào thì nó sẽ thấy đưa cái đít mày
ở đây Đúng rồi nó chiếm được đến tận đây
của cái của cái màn hình nên Thành A -
50 có phải nó nhảy sang bên này các bạn
để 50 vậy đó
chứ không phải là cái Kitty này xa so
với thằng heo này là 50 cái cầu cái chữ
này nó không cách nhau như thế mà bản
chất nó là cả cái đít Nó chiếm nó như
thế để ngoại đây Các bạn thấy cái đi vào
dài ạ Cái này về bản chất nó chiếm hết
cả bằng một giọng nếu thằng Kitty nó
cách hàng ngày 50 bếp theo bên phải nó
sẽ như thế này điều hòa tiếp theo giờ sự
cho nó lên chơi cùng để đã
ốp là không thì nó sẽ để đến trên nó sẽ
nằm ngay cạnh vào kiểu như thế này các
bạn hoàn toàn điều chỉnh nó ví dụ là -
10 Tết
nó sẽ lại chui chui dần lên kiểu thế ở
chung nhà Ừ
cái này thì
thì mình chỉ ăn giảng để các bạn hiểu
tương đối các bạn người ấy sáng bài tập
này thì các bạn sẽ hiểu kỹ hơn vì nó
đúng không lại nhảy sang Mai tập nhá Nó
cho biết qua là có 3 loại Ok đúng không
Ok
để làm bài tập cho nó hiệp
các bạn được cái ảnh này cũng ngọn ảnh
này Bây giờ mình mình sẽ để cho cái đít
chai này Mình thấy ghi ở trên này nhưng
ngoài thường mình thích kiểu ở đây thì
các bạn dễ nhớ việc và thằn lằn có là
thằng cha là con gì cả thì sẽ sai nó
giao tiếp này là thằng này sẽ lại size
cho nó là appsolute này
và khi mà mình làm hai xong các bạn sẽ
thấy à cái ảnh nó gần ngựa nó sẽ độc lập
không liên quan đến cái đít nữa và anh
có thể chùi ra ngoài cái đít xóa đây cho
ID này
nhạc Trịnh hay cho nó là sự là 200 PT
cho nào đó các bạn sẽ thấy à Cái ảnh vào
độc lập chùa Hà nở ra clip Nếu giả sử
mình lại xóa đoạn này đi nhá các bạn
thấy đó
Ừ từ cao trong trường hợp này vẫn trôi
nhưng mà đang nói đó nếu mà Tí mày cái
thằng kia cũng là poison thì nó sẽ không
trồi đâu đây mình thường
thử không ông lại ngồi bảo tôi chém gió
đi
xe
tải clip dưới này các bạn để ý đâu
cho biết giấy sai trái
bình tĩnh Tôi nhớ Tôi dạy bài này quen
rồi
đấy Nếu không thấy không chạy khi mà để
cái này thằng dưới này và liên tiếp để
cho cái ảnh ở dưới này nó nhảy xuống
dưới này nó là appsolute đoạn 2 cũng
mạnh bị đè lên B lý do mà ông phải bắt
buộc để cái này thành
áp-xe Plus ạ
Ê bà chị cho nó z-index nữa
Cái này vẫn đúng nhá Không phải tôi bảo
ờ Angeles đây là chả tác dụng điều nghe
nó vẫn đúng bởi vì à Toàn bộ ảnh trong
này chuẩn nó là
hình ảnh này ảnh này ảnh này anh đây
hình ảnh này thì tôi không biết ông dùng
bây giờ không chắc nhưng mà mấy cái ảnh
này đều là absolute trừ khi ông thích
kiểu để Fix it không được kiểu dạng là
ông Kéo xuống kéo này xuống cái này nó
chạy chéo nhớ cái này chị theo không Mỗi
ngày đó ngoại trừ khi cả Manu ấy chạy
theo còn được như tôi thấy cái Menu lại
cố định hơn thì hợp lý hơn cái ảnh này
thì nó chiếm được một góc này của chữ cứ
nghĩ là
nó vẫn là áp sống lâu nay chẳng qua cái
đoạn này em tự xuống dòng thôi
ừ ừ
cho con cái này có thể được Facebook này
hệ Fisher này
ạ Và bây giờ tại sao tự nhiên mình phải
đề cập phải cái z-index luôn rồi gì ạ
ờ ờ Các bạn thấy rõ ràng hàng ngày nó
đang nằm đè lên hàng này đúng ạ thì kệ
cái việc để mà yêu Tiên Thằng nào nằm đè
lên thằng Thằng nào Thằng nào sẽ được
hiển thị nổi bật hơn thằng nào thì mình
sẽ gắn điểm của xander mới ngẫm mặc định
như bọn nó đều đang mặc định không thì
vậy Nghĩa thằng nào xinh nó sau rồi sẽ
được chiến thắng trước thì phải Kiểu cái
Thế thế bây giờ mình sẽ thử để cho thằng
này thành thường có thích thường hay làm
phóng lại đây lại xóa ra chán cho 99 ý
trả nó không thằng nào nó sẽ redlink lớn
hơn thì sẽ trồi lên chơi như thế này
ở
đây tiếp theo là tôi làm cái ảnh ở dưới
hai đúng ạ
ừ ừ
à à
ở đây
hình ảnh hoa vàng nội ngoại Tôi Thấy Hoa
Vàng Trên Cỏ Xanh
à à
máy cày tự tạo bộ váy Index đi tạm bỏ
mày cái này đi
ca nhạc
đó sau đó Thì bây giờ mình sẽ một hôm
trước thì có ông chơi tạo một cái đít Ở
Đây Rồi chiếm cũng giống như hôm trước
tôi làm kiếm lần này để đẩy nó xuống
nhưng lần này mình không làm thế nữa là
mình sẽ ra thật sâu lúc này sao mình cho
boss tâm là không thấy trả nặng thì nó
sẽ nhảy xuống dưới Ồ nó không ạ Và nó
muốn nhảy sang bên này thì chị em Dàn
cho nó to lên đúng không Mình thể cho
kích cỡ to lên thường có nghệ kích cỡ à
Hay là cứ cho 110 phần trăm nghìn không
biết được không Chưa thực đó Ờ vậy được
rồi nó bọn nó sẽ trồi ra một tí kiểu như
thế
anh xóa đoạn hay đi cho đỡ xấu này à
Ừ nó các bạn sẽ thấy nó trôi ra đúng
không ạ
Ừ cái này mình chỉ đang dạy các bạn ở
mức tương đối thì giao diện để các bạn
về sau có hiểu qua cái này thôi chứ các
bạn Mình
thực tế mình áp dụng với này hình như
chưa bao giờ mình chị đúng kiểu chỉ đi
dậy thôi Mình trước là tác dụng cái này
thực tế bao giờ cả thế nên là các bạn
nghe rõ đoạn này Có thể bây giờ hiểu Có
thể bây giờ rất là hiểu Trọng có thể làm
được luôn đấy nhưng mà không biết về sau
các bạn với được áp dụng hay không Bởi
mình chưa Rồi áp dụng này
thì nên là các bạn nào mà đa không hiểu
lại càng chẳng phải lo gì ạ không quá
nhẹ đâu nha anh
Ừ nhưng mà mình vẫn phải dậy đúng không
dậy cho các bạn hình dung người khác bố
cục qua với các thứ của sẽ nó thế còn
mấy ông tự nhiên bây giờ bọ Bỏ không học
nữa đâu nhé
Thấy thì đây Có ảnh không ạ Và cái ảnh
này tôi để picture thì cũng được không ạ
picture thì nó khó chịu một điểm là phí
xịt thì nó sẽ tuân theo nó chẳng tuân
theo thằng cha con mà cả các bạn phải
chỉnh cho nó mức tương đối so với thằng
Ba đi thôi
à à
Ừ mình cốc bắt em mà mình cũng không hẳn
liên quan thuật toán nhà mình cốt liên
quan đến xử lý các từ thứ tình cảm thấy
nó sẽ vui và cậu thú vị hơn về cái giao
diện này vì giao diện này đau đầu cực vì
sau các bạn là nó diện này các bạn thấy
đau lâu cực căn chỉnh căn chỉnh từng cái
một tốn hết thời gian
à à
anh nói chung là ok Cái này fish được
này để tôi làm nốt cái quả thí sinh thì
ông mà nó thì gửi ảnh ngoài cùng này
cũng được sông để tiếp sức cho nó không
sao cả lại bình thường à
xe bướm một này không ạ
141 đấy mùng 4 này tại A
cô giáo sư của tôi hơn như thế này thì
mấy ông sẽ thấy cái ảnh xuống đây đúng ạ
Nhưng nếu để spam nó fake
version efficient này à
Ừ
thì nó sẽ kiểu
Ừ nó vẫn ở dưới nhưng chẳng qua mình
chưa quy ước nó nằm nằm ở đâu là lang bị
truy cùng dưới thôi Tính hệ để cho nó
lại ví dụ là tốp
là 200 PC cả
đó sau đó thì
Black là 200 mét nữa
đó là được đúng không ạ những cái này
nhược điểm cái này liên quan vì cái giao
diện đấy nhưng qua liên quan để kích cỡ
màn hình các bạn màu da như này trông
cái cái này nó sẽ bị sai đóng ngoặc bởi
vì 200 tế thì thiệu cự cố định thì cách
hợp lý hơn với vẫn là absolute
tiếp oxalat Xong rồi nó nằm kiểu đính
theo gái đít này thì nó chuẩn hơn này
đúng không ạ
Ừ để em một cách hò gà các bạn phải
chỉnh nó theo tỷ lệ phần trăm gì đấy nữa
Cái này thì mình không rõ lắm nhưng Đại
thay thế như bài hôm nay không chỉ có
mỗi choline thế này bà hôm nay thì mình
định là mình đặt tên tiêu đề Nó lao mình
xin phép và dậy hôm nay bà hôm nay kiến
thức rất là dài các bạn chịu khó nghe
hơi nhiều tí tề Mà buổi sau rồi còn như
là mình sẽ cũng tương đối tương đối gần
như xong rồi cái CF này ra để mình xem
lại xem à
anh Thưởng đẩy về slide của mình slide
này không mặt slide đâu Cái này là
a slide because ở đâu Về
lapisschool 2 trang nào ấy
à à
nhớ lại buổi sao mình chắc là mình sẽ
nói qua nốt với mấy cái á
booc-đô lẫn cả cm còn hôm nay mình sẽ
nói toàn bộ về lây out
anh không Hôm nay mình không bị màu
slide đâu slide đấy nó có trên mạng các
bạn hoàn toàn thể lên đã đưa school có
rất nhiều
ở nhà mình sẽ không mở lại những cái mà
rõ dài các bạn thì tìm ở trên mạng
anh không hôm mình không dậy chưa bằng
cái clip mà mình sẽ chỉ nói qua về cái
việc tao này bố cục tao nó là gì nữa đây
em giả sử như bây giờ mình lại quay lại
kể
cái mẫu cũ nhá á
ạ
Bây giờ mình sẽ chưa có một cái hắn một
thảm mục đích thì một cái H1 cũng được
cái lâu chẳng ạ
khi mình chạy thử đấy
ừ ừ
ạ Bây giờ giả sử là bây giờ mình để cái
nền của cái chữ Hello nền của cái thẻ H1
này là
bác ra đúng mà mình cho nên nó màu đỏ
chẳng ạ ra xử thế thì theo các bạn thì
nên nó sẽ phụ phí người đâu ạ
à à
mở màn trước nhé em
em nói nhỏ
Anh theo các bạn thì cái nền của cái thẻ
hắn một này sẽ phụ phí đến đâu
ừ ừ
Anh
[âm nhạc]
ở toàn chữ h 1
đi ngang qua à
ở Vĩnh Yên bây giờ chat thở chẳng có bạn
nào có thể
Em có thể trả trả lời đầy đủ được nó bởi
vì a chẳng có bạn hiểu về cái đấy
em hết lòng thì là nọ chuyển mức tương
đối rồi Đúng mà để mình thử cho bạn xem
à web nhưng nhìn nhầm nhầm nhầm đấy đây
khi nó thực sự không phải hết lòng nó
không cũng không thể chỉ phụ mỗi chữ
Hello đúng hoặc Tại sao mình nói không
phải hết dòng Bởi vì thực sự thì nó vẫn
còn thua khoảng trống ở đây ở đây Đồng
hoặc nó chiều cao thì nó cũng sẽ khách
hàng h11 tí đúng không và toàn bộ những
cái này mình biết là thông qua cái gì
bản chất là
về mặt bản chất là nó sẽ thông qua cái
các bạn ấn ấn inspect này Chỗ các bạn
kéo xuống dưới này các bạn sẽ xem được
bố cục của nó đúng không ạ Và Nó
về bản chất là thằng này nó mình nhớ
mình nhớ hồi đấy mình được dậy cái cách
ví dụ này rất dễ hiểu và dễ nhớ cho các
bạn thì các bạn cứ hình dung mà cái
thằng này nó làm cái cái mình đang chỉ
đây nhá nó nhà nó bạn này thì
nhà các bạn nó sẽ rộng đúng kiểu ngay và
cái màu đỏ là không gian nhà các bạn
đóng lại nó sẽ nha à
Ừ thì ở đây cái việc mà cái khoảng
khoảng cách giữa cái chữ Hello này với
cái với cái viền của cái nhà này
Ừ cái trò đấy có cái viền không ạ thì
thì nó sẽ thông qua Gõ cái gọi bác đi
này à
và đương nhiên các bạn thấy nó nằm sát
với nhau nhìn này Thực ra nó đang dựa
sát vào nhau đấy đây mình sẽ cho nó cái
bơ thì các bạn sẽ dùng nhé
một mười bếp này sony's này và Baek Hee
trở lại
i10 hơi quá Nam Định à
thì các bạn thấy đó là rõ ràng trong
trường hợp này nó đang dựa sát vào nhau
rồi bởi vì nó không hiểu khoảng trống
nhì trong căn nhà đó bạn để ngoài Thế là
mình muốn cho khoảng trống giữa đồ đạc
với cái tưởng bức tường thì nó sẽ là
mình sẽ khái niệm là bác Đinh
nếu mà các bạn ghi như thế này Đầu tiên
thì cách cách ghi của cái việc
mơ đây rồi bác Ninh này hay tím mình sẽ
có cả máu kinh thì nếu mà các bạn không
ghi gì không ghi cậu xuộc nhanh do ngồi
các thử làm sau nó sẽ hiểu là bác đình
này nó sẽ là cả bốn khắp trên dưới trái
phải đầy đủ Còn nếu các bạn muốn chỉ ghi
góp theo cả và muốn Bác định Bush tâm
này kẹo cách ở dưới ấy rủ hai mươi Tết
chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ cách cái đồ đạc các
bạn sẽ cách cái bức tường đúng không ạ
hai
triệu rưỡi đúng không đấy
em tắt đi nhìn các bạn sẽ hiểu là như
thế nghĩa là cái thứ nó vẫn nằm ở trong
căn nhà các bạn Tại sao tự nhiên nãy giờ
mình để cập căn nhà bởi vì ở đây nó sẽ
còn thêm khái niệm cũng về cái cắt nữa
cũng về cách nhau nữa các bạn sẽ thấy à
Nó có cái máy này nó cũng là cách và nó
dạy cách các bạn thấy nó cách ra khỏi
cái á
khiến cho nó thừa khoảng trống màu trắng
trắng ở đây em ạ đúng không Bởi vì nó
đang mắt nhìn đấy nó ra mắt nhìn
vi phạm đây các bạn phải là Morgan 8
Đúng không Nó cách cách ra 8
em giả sử Lý xóa cái Morgan đi thì các
bạn sẽ thấy
à À không mình sẽ cho hẳn một cái đít
nữa đi nó cái đít nữa thì các bạn sẽ dễ
hình dung hơn là sự nhà bạn với nhà hàng
xóm đi
về nhà bạn này
đây là nhà Crush đi mấy ông thích kiểu
tình nghĩa của tình yêu
Hãy trợ ngay á sử nhà ông với nha Crush
nó đang cậu cách nhau như thế này đúng
không ạ ạ
thì các bạn sẽ thấy da nó mặc định sẽ có
thêm vào đoạn moggi Để nhà không Sắp
thằng sạc nhau không ạ và rõ là cái vùng
không hề có mụn đỏ nào ở giữa cái đoạn
này tất cả
cái cái mồi sáng này nó thực ra nó chẳng
thuộc của ai Cả đúng không Nó giống kiểu
cái sân đấy nó giống như cái khoảng
trống giữa hai nhà nó không nó của chung
nó chẳng của ai cả nên là không có mũ đỏ
nào ở đấy đâu mà đánh dấu chủ quyền và
sự nhà của người yêu màu hồng đi Đúng
rồi đấy thì rõ ràng là nó sẽ không
thì nó sẽ không kiểu dạng nó sẽ không
một hôm cả chỗ này không màu đỏ chỗ này
luôn đúng không ạ Và cái Mác Lênin này
nó sẽ khoảng trống chung như thế nhưng
ngoài ra hình như mình vừa nói nó là cái
sân thôi bà cái sân này nó vẫn có ạ
Ừ nó vẫn có thể có cái kiểu hàng rào đây
đây các bạn phân biệt nhé Đây là tưởng
các bạn 3 đây là Tường này như các bạn
vẫn sẽ có thêm hàng rào ở cái đoạn sân
này nữa họ sẽ gọi là ảo like cái đoạn
này nó hơi bị đau não không Tí
đây là sự mình anh cũng 15 phế cũng
solys và lần này bị cho nó màu gì nhé
màu xanh đi
ở đó Thì cái này nó là hẳn cái Online
này ở ở trên này nó bị lỗi nó không hiển
thị đầy đủ cả cào online lại bị chữa bạn
xem
em có bạn sẽ thấy là
ừ ừ
đi kẻo lại nha nó sẽ là chứa chứa luôn
tất cả
thì nó sẽ kiểu nó chứa luôn cả cái cái
hạt cái khoảng trống sân các bạn chứa
luôn cả ba đây chúng cả bác đinh và các
thứ thứ và khi các bạn bôi màu cho váy
nhà các bạn như thế này thì bạn chất nó
sẽ chỉnh nằm trong cái phạm vi Bác Đinh
và cả nhà thôi chứ nó không hề bôi cho
Bơ Vơ không bôi cho Martin không cho bôi
tro Lai đúng không ạ
thì tại sao tự nhiên nãy mình phải cập
cái khá lằng nhằng này bởi vì về sau các
bạn nếu mà tính toán về cái việc là cái
đít này chiếm bao nhiêu
tế cái chiếm bao nhiêu vị khoảng khoảng
không là chiếm hết đúng không thì các
bạn phải tính hết toàn bộ con số này với
nhau thế nay có trường hợp mà hôm trước
mình nói đó là thật sự là bây giờ mình
cho hai cái đít em mình sẽ sửa lại cái
này Tí
đây Style báo não đoạn này Thực sự thì
mình thấy nó cũng hơi bị đau não cũng
chả biết giải thích nhà
1B sony's này Black này à
số tiền này bận à Nhà bạn
a tiếp theo
sử dụng trường hợp này là
nhà người yêu bạn Màu hồng này thật sự
là này không nằm kiểu trên nhau nữa mà
sẽ ra flash lép nằm ngay sát cạnh nhau
đi
à
hài sẽ là Quýt là 50 phần trăm
hai cũng sẽ quýt 50 phần trăm này à
à à
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là cho dù Hai thằng
nhà đều 50 phần trăm của màn hình đúng à
nhưng mà các bạn thấy rõ ràng là nó vẫn
sẽ 7 nhau xuống bởi vì sao Vì như mình
vừa nói đó là ba đời này nó vẫn tính vào
khoảng cách đúng không ta sử mình xóa
cái bao đời đi này Xóa bức tường đi
đường á
thì hai bạn với sát được với nhau đúng
hay nhà sẽ là sạc nhau kiểu không có
tưởng nữa nữa thì không không ra luôn
đúng không ạ Còn trường hợp mà có tưởng
thì nó sẽ không không tính mà váy phạm
vi nhà của ông ngoan không tính và cái
vít 50 phần trăm này nó sẽ Cộng rồi thêm
+ rồi Thế em phải ra nó sẽ đầy thằng kia
xuống đấy và tương tự Thế thì như mình
vừa nói cái quýt này nó sẽ thì tỉnh Bắc
Ninh thôi còn mát ghim các bạn cộng thêm
nó cũng sẽ đẩy xuống ao like cộng thêm
nó sẽ đẩy xuống đường ăn ạ thì nó sẽ đẩy
ngôi nhà người yêu anh xuống không còn
thông ra nữa đấy em mấy ông phá cứ tưởng
nó đi
ok đấy đấy toàn bộ thực ca vừa rồi nói
có vẻ rất là khó hiểu thế nhưng đây lại
ở toàn bộ những cái các bạn cần biết về
lights
em còn ông làm à Nhớ không nhớ thì sẽ
xem lại chưa thấy ta mình mình bảo toàn
bộ cái kiến thức mình dậy
thì các bạn không cần phải nhớ lắm Vì
mình áp dụng với ít nếu mà các bạn muốn
xem về bên bác ạ
à Còn bây giờ thì mình sẽ nói qua một tí
bài tập nhá Hôm nay kiến thức thế đủ đấy
sợ quá Tại mấy ông nữa 3 bài tập gì à
Ừ nếu mà ông dặn thì mày không có thể
làm lại bài hôm trước theo phong cách
mùa xuân
anh kia nên dùng Tết và khi nào nên dùng
phần trăm à
chị Xuka thì à Nói như thế nào nhỉ
đón một thì các bạn làm theo phong cách
nạp được giao diện chỉ cần đỡ đau mắt
chia bố cục được là được còn như ẩm thực
tế giống như bạn kia nói thì sẽ nó liên
quan di bo xit tức à về tương thích với
rất nhiều giao diện nữa và cái này thì
có nhiều cái giống như bút tráp nó hỗ
trợ rồi
WeChat này nó
A Town để nó hỗ trợ các bạn với chỉnh
giao diện cấp thứ thứ rồi nên các bạn
chẳng cần phải nhớ để phần trăm bao
nhiêu phần trăm bao nhiêu Tết nữa
giống như về xong mình chạy về các bạn
ăn cắp báo diện về các bạn thực sự các
bạn chỉ cần biết chỉnh nó một vài cái
hôi trước các bạn không cần phải chú
trọng nó bao nhiêu Tết thì bao nhiêu
phần trăm nữa
tim mình đi những cái thứ mà hơn một nửa
những thứ câu hỏi mà các bạn đang thắc
mắc bây giờ thì xong các bạn sẽ hiểu hết
nhớ đưa nhân vì sao các bạn lại thắc mắc
cái khác
lại các bạn thể làm lại bài này bài này
các bạn sẽ thấy theo force mẹ nó sẽ hợp
lý hơn cũng chưa chia bố cục ảnh như thế
không ạ
Và một bài này nữa này Cái bài
Bài này ý đây mình sẽ đừng nói qua bạn
này bài này thì mấy ông sẽ thời đó là
cái này bắt buộc phải liên quan hệ gen
Jack này ba cây mấy cái ảnh này không
liên quan Tôi sợ lắm cái này bản chất là
nó chỉ ở dưới Yên đấy để nó trồi ra được
như thế này cái hợp việc là cái này là
phiền viền ảnh đấy nhé Chứ không có viên
là bệnh màu nghe đâu
a tiếp theo là
à À không phải viền mà nó bát rau nhà
bác lao Anh và tương tự đằng sau này có
bác lao này sẽ có một phom lại có thứ B1
bài tổng hợp tương đối
à à
gì hả Mấy cái bài tập này thời mà tôi đi
dạy ở trường mà tôi không biết được bài
này lấy từ đâu nữa Lỡ kệ thôi
à à
thế
nhưng mấy cái này mới sẽ thể hiện rõ
người ông cách chia bố cục những thứ
chẳng lẽ tôi lấy sự giao diện của
Facebook về
nếu người làm ở có khi ấy vài tổng hợp
cô ấy cái
khóa CF này tôi sẽ bắt mấy ông làm một
cái trang web mạng xã hội nào đó Ừ
ở đây đầu tiên ít tập vẫn như điệp khúc
ID laptop sẽ là Quýt một trăm phần trăm
hay là 700 Tết cho ạ
Ừ mình vẫn ở luôn điệp khúc cho cái bát
rau cho nó làm cái mẫu bình thường lắm
mẫu vẫn phải nên để màu chói các bạn
kiểu nhìn thấy mình đang sai đúng không
ạ
à à
a tiếp theo cái màu bị trùng ở nhà để
cho màu đỏ ạ
ở đó sau đó thì mình sẽ có cái đít Các
bạn thấy thật ra ở đây nó bản chất đấy
bản chất ở đây Nếu ông Để ý kỹ thì ông
thấy rõ ra là cái cái cái con bạch tuộc
còn phải tội con mực chỗ không nhớ đã nó
sẽ nằm ra cả bên này tức là tôi ở cái
này cái đít cái này là một ít nhưng mà
cái đít này nó có thể poison này nó sẽ
cho lơ lửng thôi chứ không phải là có
một cái đít đây để tôi mở cái này bằng
tên mấy ông dễ hiểu nhé
à à
em có một cái đít đấy đúng
ở đầu tiên có một tí tổng nói rồi không
có cái đi vào đây để chữa con mực này và
nền đen không ạ một cái đít đây nữa là
để có cái backgroud lại inmax lại chính
là cái viên bảy sắc cầu vồng này và
không phải là cái Điệp ở đây nữa như này
và một cái đít vào đây nữa như thế này
đâu
1000 mà nó sẽ là người đít nữa to như
thế này
D3 gà đít này nó bạn chất là nó sẽ có
bác lao chính là cái con con bạch tuộc à
Mày bạch tuộc đâu nó nó còn sữa đấy ở
đây nữa Đều Ngoan
ạ sau đó thì mới có thêm
chữ của đây con vân nó ngoan sau một cái
đít ở đây thì không thấy rồi và một cái
clip ở đây đấy
Ừ nếu không thấy có phải nhiều lý vừa
ngon mà ông cướp đã về sau thử làm cái
copy cái mạng xã hội đó về đi hoạt động
chị ạ chàng giao diện đơn giản nhất đúng
như của thằng Google ấy có một cái Hãy
tìm kiếm không nó không thử vào trang
đấy người lớn cân cho new xem nó có bao
nhiêu lít thì ông ấy mấy ông mới sẽ hiểu
là nó diện mệt như nào ạ
ở
nhà ông thử luôn đi lên Google thử thử
ăn kenjo xem
Anh ấy thanh tìm kiếm của nó không phải
là cái hành tìm kiếm mà nó tạo bởi đít
và thêm xe đó có bồ đấy tôi ngồi xem sợ
vậy
Ừ anh
Ờ Ờ
mình sẽ có đít ở bên trái không ạ Chị sẽ
là này thì dễ thôi Mình rất là tên là dụ
đi trai đi phải không Thứ Không sao mà
thôi tự nhiên ở đây Thằng này nó không
phải trái nhỉ họ giữa mình đã tên nó đi
và đấy Có san hô nhé Mình nhớ không lầm
là cái ảnh này tên là San hồn ngờ Con
này nó san hô clip san hô đây mình sẽ có
à à
bí
quyết đã ba mươi phần trăm này
32 là một trăm phần trăm của thằng cha
này rồi Tuy nhiên background sẽ màu đen
ngoan ạ
ta có
Ừ rồi
a tiếp theo mình sẽ có ảnh không ạ
xe tải mình nhớ nó san hô mà
à à
Âm Nhạc
thì các bạn thấy ra thứ cá ở mặc định nó
đã nhảy sang bên này rồi bây giờ ra thứ
hai không đúng đâu vì các bạn zoom ra
zoom và như này nó sẽ không không phù
hợp lại đóng ngoặc mình muốn rút ra rút
vào nó vẫn nhảy thì chọn ở đây là cái
xe buýt của nó lên kiểu lớn hơn cái đít
thì nó sẽ ổn hơn sự wisi nó này có ít
cho nó đấy và 110 phần trăm tiếp đi
thế này
ở đó thì mình dùng đang vui vào nó sẽ
hiểu luôn lớn hơn trong vẻ ổn hơn nó
ngon tiếp anh sẽ nhớ đơn như chỉnh mức
tương đối rồi nó không ạ
Có cái đít nữa
Có ai đi beat viền em ạ chẳng biết tên
clip này ngao nữa ra nó có cái bát rau
với viên thôi
sẽ có
quýt là mười phần trăm của trở lại mình
sẽ lại 200 và backgroud lần này bác
lionmass cho chuẩn đi mua lô này tự chọn
lên điện ảnh Cái ảnh chị gửi ảnh sọc đen
song
song với viên nhỏ như nhau thôi đúng
không
anh nghe tự nhiên nó bị thế này phải đổi
anh cắn chuồn áp này đội nón hình này
ta có
ở đó đi Ở đây sẽ là sạc à
à à
Ừ
nó bị chu thường dừa Đúng không Một mình
thiếu flash led
ở nhà đó
Ừ đấy thì các bạn thấy rõ ràng hàng ngày
nó trôi ra bị cắt mất rồi không thấy một
là ông chơi position hai ông dùng
z-index tùy đời mình dùng gel nách cũng
được
99 chàng ạ ạ
37 vẫn không không được
ừ ừ
Ừ hình như trong trường hợp này là đúng
ở phải có đi Sơn thật thì thử nhé á
Anh không ngờ lắm rồi vụ này lắm đâu Tôi
xin nó rơi tiếp này
hay sẽ vô sinh
appsolute này
đó mày không thể truy ra chưa đó không
phải cứ sẽ đến đấy cả được đúng hoặc bởi
vì thằng ngày
nhà hàng ngày Nếu mà nó dậy đất cho mỗi
đây Để tôi giải thích cho anh cái đoạn
này bởi vì
nếu mà cái ảnh nó nằm trong cái ít thôi
thì nếu mà ông z-index cho cái ảnh thôi
được vẫn chả ảnh hưởng gì ở Bởi vì cả
cái đít này nó cũng không nằm trên clip
kia ông ạ Thế à Bây giờ ông Chỉnh cái
bôi sơn xong ấy thì nó không theo quy
tắc kiểu của cái á của cái la iCloud của
cái chia chia có hai thằng nó bằng nhau
nữa mà cái ảnh này là sự độc lập nó
không liên quan dừng dán này thằng ít
nữa hai thằng đít này vẫn có thể bằng
nhau nhé nghĩa bằng cấp nhau như cái
xanh ảnh này nó sẽ không liên quan hơn
thằng nó sẽ không nằm Nhưng cái đít nữa
mà nó sẽ nằm Độc Lập
ô tội chẳng đi giải thích thêm như thế
nào nữa
ở lại khái nói gì thế
em cứ bảo ông không hiểu thì tạm chấp
nhận về sau không động vào nữa
tiếp theo đây
Anh tên ID đã beat-up
anh sữa ngon sữa Vừa thấy có ảnh hưởng
có sữa nóng ngon à a bít sữa này đi xe
buýt
ý là
30 10
U60 phần trăm à
ừ ừ
à à
các bác down Max
30 tuổi nhìn thấy tên này Điện thoại nhớ
lại
Ừ có thì các bạn nhớ về cái mình từng
nói đó là Ừ cái á
thứ nhất là cái bát rồi à cái bát
primate như này thì ở nhà nó là bác ra
trong suốt cái ảnh ở trong suốt nên
thành ra nó đang bị thưởng màu này thôi
thẩn nó đi sẽ không còn màu này nữa
nhưng mà tiếp theo là mình muốn cho cái
ảnh đó là duy nhất mà nó cắn nó giữ đúng
không ạ thì mình xe backgroud repeat
không ạ ạ
a
lipid
repeat
đó tiếp theo là mình có thể cắn nó giữa
là bác round Ocean
Từ Sơn là Center sẽ cân bằng giữa này nó
hơi lì hơn nó mắt ạ
Ừ nó sau đó thì các bạn bây giờ chị cần
thêm cái này làm cái đít nữa này cái này
một cái đít nữa là ngon đi mà Chưa Thay
bồ cái này nó chửi thấy bồi nhá các bạn
thấy nó rắn thẳng hàng như này sẽ thả nó
lên quan hệ bổ này đúng không ạ
chị đánh sao sau đó thì cái đít này nữa
thì mình tôi sợ nó là
kiểu picture cũng được hoặc nhá
appsolute vì các bạn ngon đấy các bạn sẽ
về làm bài này nhé
anh còn bài không trước các bạn muốn sửa
lại để cho trông nó đẹp cũng được bởi vì
mình thấy các bạn nộp cũng tương đối rồi
ừ ừ
ạ Bây giờ thì cũng cần chính nhân 9g của
mình chị xinh cách chia sẻ về cái á
I had ơ ơ
cái này mình đang viết tắt để cho các
bạn không đoán được thử các bạn trai
trên Google nó chữ ra thôi đã tin lời
Chị nói là Open grab ôtô gì gì đó thực
ra là cái này thì các bạn có nhiều bạn
chưa biết cái này nó liên quan đến nằm
mình ghi hết Bơ vì nó nằm trong thẻ
header của cái file HM Minh từng nói cái
gì nó sẽ nằm trong thẻ hét của htl nó sẽ
là thứ nhất là có thể xê hết để mà cái
trong cuộc để mà báo trước cho trang web
là nên hiển thị cái htl da trông như thế
nào Cái thứ nhất thứ hai là thẻ Meta cho
Xét để biết được trang này nó có Lựu có
hiển thị ra ngôn ngữ là cậu là Unicode
hay không ạ Hay thù là để mà hiển thị
trên thanh tiêu đề là đúng không ạ Và
thêm cái nữa nó là thẻ Meta thấy Meta
này và nó thêm những routing khác để mà
cho các công cụ tìm kiếm tấm như thằng
Google hoặc là à à
ở gần như thằng Google hoặc là thằng
Facebook để mình đọc qua được trang web
các bạn chứ thực ra nó không đặt toàn bộ
htl các bạn để biết trang web hoặc các
bạn là cái gì đâu đấy thế thế nên là các
bạn sẽ thêm những cái này và do sự bây
giờ Đương nhiên mình không cho trang web
ở công khai nên mình sẽ không có ví dụ
mà mình sẽ dùng một trang của mình hãy
xin chọn lọc chấm com
sự tranh ai chẳng ạ
xe tải gắn kansuru này
Ừ đấy thì các bạn thấy ra hồi đấy mình
đã làm một loạt các thẻ Meta mặc định
của thằng bồ nó hỗ trợ nó một loạt này
này này URL này hay thu là gì này ảnh
mình sẽ hiển thị ra lúc mà kiểu tết nó
xa một cái trang web Nó bất kỳ này giá
sự nhé Thì sẽ copy cái này Lúc mà
bị nhầm
thế này
ủng hộ mình bằng máy mới không Mình sẽ
copy ra như thế này nó sẽ đọc nhanh cái
trang web của mình không phải chọn ảnh
đầu tiên mà nó sẽ theo cái thẻ Metal này
lấy được cái ảnh là đường Linh ảnh này
số hiển thị ảnh ra như nào vân vân vân
mô tả qua cái ảnh là
[âm nhạc]
em nhớ chúng ta của mình khó là không Mở
nhạc thì lỗi
em
đau đầu
em có ra ra được ngay hình ảnh này của
mình hình như bị chết rồi Thời gian là
không ra gửi ảnh Thì phải đúng rồi Cái
đường Linh này của mình như chết rồi máy
tính phải cập nhật lại nhớ đấy các bạn
dễ hình dung vừa rồi à
Ừ đúng rồi Cái này liên quan đến việc
sale nữa sale kiểu để mà cho đẩy lên các
công cụ tìm kiếm mà không ạ
hai kỳ
Ừ thì đây Đây là một ví dụ thôi các bạn
hoàn toàn thể lên điều lớp ơ
facebook.com nhóm này các bạn đọc qua
được việc à
A1
Anh tắt máy tính
ờ ờ
ê ê
anh đọc qua được là là cái cái Facebook
nó sẽ đọc trang web các bạn như thế nào
các bạn sẽ kéo xuống dưới ở đây có sự
thay thế này này nó đọc qua cái bộ thẻ
Meta để nhận diện được là cậu trang web
Portal là gì có người thứ hiển thị ảnh
đấy luôn Cái này có một ví dụ rất là hay
khi mà các bạn kiểu bây giờ các bạn một
công khai trang web các bạn đúng oan cho
các bạn sẽ lên đây để mà đi box để mà
xem Nó thực sự trong web các bạn khi
chia sẻ trong nó sẽ nhau trên Facebook
hoặc trên với gì đó ví dụ ở sử trong
trường hợp này của mình vừa rồi mình bảo
bị lỗi ngày đúng ngoạn cho mình cần nhận
lại ảnh ở trên trang này đúng không ạ
thì mình sẽ lên đây để mình ấn stress
với game này cho nó sẽ cậu sẽ kiểu lấy
lại thông tin lại cái Chanh em một lần
nữa
Ừ
thì nó xảy ra được chuyện như thế là sự
mình Ví dụ ở đây nhá mình sẽ copy đường
link này
Ừ mình đến đây thôi thử nhé
Ừ
cái này nó Con bảo là cái đường Linh này
đã từng được chia sẻ trên Facebook Hồi
trưa này thật sự thế
à à
anh em bây giờ chưa từng ngồi chia sẻ
nên để lần đầu tiên lấy nó không ạ thì
nó sẽ ra những cái gì đấy nó sẽ ra được
cái các thứ thứ như thế này gần như là
các công cụ các công cụ chỉnh kiểu giả
khi các bạn chia sẻ lên động thế chứ sẻ
qua tin nhắn Messenger hoa cà
Instagram hoặc và Twitter các bạn đăng
cái gì lên thì đăng một cái YouTube Vì
Đó là sự à lý do để bạn không ạ
anh
nghe nhạc
à à
hình ảnh như này thì các bạn có thể lên
được các bạn mà chia sẻ công khai luôn
là ông kia kiểu Tao muốn lừa mày vào cái
trang web này đúng không ạ nhưng mà
nhưng mà khi mà gửi cái link này cho
thằng kia thì nói hiển thị ra xử cái
tiêu đề vẫn cả cái ảnh rồi Thằng kia
không thể bị lừa được không ạ Thế nên là
hoàn toàn các bạn thể đánh lừa Bằng cách
này các bạn
tạo ra một cái trang web
số trang web với bản chất của nó sẽ điều
hướng sang cái trang web do này đúng rồi
nhưng mà ông để mê ta og sẽ là kiểu
Cậu Linh 18 + chỉ ai mới trên 18 tuổi
Đưa xem cái này Đấy thu hút cho bé ông
ấy đàn ông Click vào đấy Kiểu thế rồi
Click vào luôn Nhưng nếu ngoại điều
hướng danh thời trang nhưng thật
nhưng mà cái thảm mấy cái thằng này đọc
thì nó sẽ chỉ đọc qua cái ô ô og của ông
thôi hoàn toàn nó không đọc được thực sự
trang web Trông nó như thế nào
đang ví dụ như thế với ông đừng có áp
dụng cái micro không dây khác
còn bạn nào mà không hiểu lý do gì nó
lại Thái rồi ra một cách lừa cũng giật
giật tít một cái gì đó so với thức ăn
nhảy sang cái bài này
ừ ừ
từ ngày tôi vừa lấy ôm mày không ấy mày
không phải nghe tiếng nhạc đấy à
à còn thời gian nghỉ tranh thủ nói qua
nốt về cái á
à tiện ích mình đang dùng nhé á
anh không biết họ không thích cái cảm
nóng nóng ở đâu Sao không Ok thì đây là
những tiện ích mình đang dùng này tiện
ích này mình mình là mình từng chia sẻ
rồi mà nó là tiện ích để chặn quảng cáo
các thứ trên là Facebook chạm những cái
thứ mà không khó chữ trên Facebook hiện
tại vì nó không dùng nữa gì học Facebook
cập nhật liên tục theo tôi sẽ là mày còn
chị những ngày sau thế nào tiện ích chặn
quảng cáo rất ngày có về thì cái cái vẫn
đang rất là ôi mình cũng không hiểu tại
sao nó vẫn tồn tại được ở trên store của
thằng Google khi mà chặn của chính hàng
Google
gia đình mình cười tiếp theo thì ít này
cái này thì có rất nhiều không sẽ có thể
thích chị ích này thì nó để như này tôi
mới lên nha rồi lại và từ kỳ vậy
Ồ tôi thích Tiki hàng shopee
chị xem được một sản phẩm này
em chia bác các bạn sẽ thấy à cái cái
tiện ích này nó sẽ hiển thị ra nó sẽ lấy
thông tin của cái sản phẩm này để để mà
lấy toàn bộ lịch sử giá của sản phẩm này
xong rồi gợi ý cho ông ở đây là giá sản
phẩm hiện tại đang ở mức như nào so với
từ trước đây ví dụ là các bạn thấy vào
đây toàn kiểm giảm giá sốc
899.000 dạng hàng còn 400 nhỉ gà ở các
ông xem lấy được ra nó chơi ở lên 8599
thì mẹ nó lừa đúng không kiểu thế nhưng
mà ông xem giá thực tế Rồi trước ngày
nay nó đúng có thay đổi thật không Vân
không phải ở cái chưa trò vớ vẩn trên
này đúng không ạ Ông tự xem thì ông kiểu
nên mua không thật chứ nó sẽ thông báo
Ông Nếu thật sự lại giá giảm hơn 1.000
nữa chắc không nói chuyện đấy đâu nhưng
mà đấy nếu mà toàn thể làm cái đấy kỳ
tích này vẫn là xịn nhất nhưng mà tôi
không hoàn hảo Quê Ừ ông cài không bị
nghiện đấy hết
Ừ tôi sẽ hướng dẫn ông làm hẳn cái tune
giống như có anh Mạnh Tuấn đang thỉnh
thoảng chia sẻ mấy cái á
số mã giảm giá trên shopee ngon thật ra
anh đấy dùng tool để mà lấy toàn bộ các
mã làm giá những cái sản phẩm đang giảm
giá hấp dẫn ông anh như sẽ chạy con boss
lập trình tạo con boss chạy tự động để
quét tất cả sản phẩm để mà ra được sản
phẩm nào có vẻ làm giá sốc vương vấn đề
mạng để mà kiểu nó ra được cả mã giảm
giá sốc luôn có thứ gì
Ừ nhưng mà ý tôi ở đây đó lại mình làm
được những cái ngon hơn thế thay mì ông
ông phải mất công ở đây ông vẫn mất
không là ông vào từng sản phẩm để ông
lướt để xem sản phẩm nào ổn hay không mà
việc mà ông lướt nhiều sẽ tạo cho ông
kích thích thì ông muốn mua những sản
phẩm mẹ thì về các bạn ấy vẫn mất tiền
kia vẫn cảm thấy được giảm giá đúng
không ạ Thế thôi từ bỏ đi
Ừ ông chỉ nên cài khi mà uống ít mua sắm
thôi bây giờ sự lên nóc nhà thôi này này
là không một lứa shopee cài thêm cái từ
nó cũng chỉ đơn giản khiến nó bạn ngồi
nước nhiều hơn
à à
Chúng tôi có một vài tiện ích thì hiện
độ lười của thấu kính khủng Và Tôi tin
là những cái người làm à tiện ích Kể
cũng thấy cũng lừa như tôi đó là cái
dụng ở khi ông tải một cái gì đó nó về
thì nó luôn hiển thị ra là kéo đây Tôi
ví dụ ông nữa
Ừ tại anh bạn này về trả
hai tay nó sẽ luôn hiển thị ra cái thành
này đôi khi nó tốt cho ông đấy Nhớ Anh
Nhiều lúc tôi không thích điều đấy tôi
sẽ có tiện ích để mà ngăn việc thành chị
ra cái kiểu như thế thôi cái rất là nhỏ
nhỏ một nhưng tôi lưỡi cưa Thế còn có
tiện ích ngày nữa thì cái kiểu ông muốn
kiểm nhân đôi Hồi trước ở không có cái
vụ này chuột phải từ đã ký kết cái Trang
đâu rồi ông ở nhân đôi trang của ông lên
Ông phải căn c cần V ngay đúng không
Nhưng mà không một lọ Tôi dùng cái kiểu
như tay những hồi đấy không có cái vụ
đấy thì tôi tập thể hạn cái tiện ích cả
nữa tốt để mà tôi bấm một phím tắt nào
đó hoặc bấm vào cái tiện ích thì nó sẽ
mở topic lên kiểu như thế
ừ ừ
a tiếp theo tiện ích này để tải toàn bộ
ảnh cũng chưa Như tớ nói rồi trên khá
như mạng xã hội
về
trễ ra để và sửa poki poki là liên quan
đến khả thương còn có kem Facebook có
thứ ấy và thơ ca về sau trong cái khóa
học này luôn Vì sao tôi sẽ giải thích
các bạn Quốc Kỳ là gì kỹ hơn cái để mà
chụp ảnh cả trang web có nghề Ông mấy
ông vẫn còn hơi bị Cậu hiểu không phải
giữ cũng mệt kiểu cầm điện thoại chụp
chụp màn hình sôi gửi cốt các tư thứ đấy
không nên này mới nhất à Ông thấy cốt mà
nhắn quá không cần bệnh đẩy lên hẳn ký
hát Thì tao khuyên mày ông dụng để trang
này họ trang các bọc carbon chấm nao
chậm cao gọi trữ carbon này xong rồi có
chuyện cốt này nóng chảy ra tra ngày
thôi đấy các bạn sẽ post ở đây sau lại
các bạn sẽ ẩn lưu lại thành giảng này số
các bạn gửi ảnh cho người ta chứ không ạ
để người ta biết được cốt các bạn cái
thứ nhất cho nước cốt các bạn dài quá
thì các bạn phải để lên hạn chế thấp này
người ta thì Xem cốt các bạn còn nếu mà
các bạn muốn chụp cái trang web vào đó
thì các bạn có thể dùng cái tiện ích
kiểu như này một loài hoa các bạn muốn
kiểu
anh ở đây Tại sao mình không để cập phải
buộc việc là các bạn có thể dùng ấn phím
ví dụ là ấn phím prince pin ở cạnh chữ s
12 tuổi mà chụp màn hình Thực ra thì
chụp màn hình nó vẫn có thể vỡ kết hợp
việc là không chụp được toàn bộ cả trang
web hoặc Còn nếu mà mày ông muốn chụp
một cái bạn đơn giản nhanh thì rõ dài
ông hoàn toàn Windows ship ép để mà chụp
cái đoạn là nhanh đúng không ạ nhưng mà
nó vẫn bị vỡ nét của ảnh Giả sử Trong
trường hợp mà ông đang rung nó Cá thứ
con kế ảnh này thì nó sẽ đúng chất lượng
nguyên xi luôn Thế nên là ông nên dùng
cái gì
Ừ cái này thì lấy mà dùng mấy cái anh
chưa để mở Excel Vân offline Vậy bỏ qua
cái này để
dịch này không ạ Cái này cái này chị
luôn đòi hỏi tôi tiền
số tự động chỉnh sửa ở lại chính tả của
mình tiếng Anh nói chuyện thế nào đòi
tiền được nâng cấp đi để máy viết ngon
hơn mà thôi
thì đi mờ
em tìm ở là để mà tải file như tuổi còn
nó qua phụ tải file rồi
Cái này để mà nó sẽ cắt nhỏ file ra để
tải file nhanh hơn không ạ
Ừ cái này và một thứ rất là hay Hồi
trước Nếu bây giờ không dùng nữa tiếp
vãi đây tôi tự cho ông Tại sao 2
anh không thấy
Ê hồi trước thằng Facebook nó có cơ chế
này nó là tìm kiếm
có một cái gì đó theo Rất rất nhiều cái
tay ông xem này tìm kiếm được tên dẫn
Anh tên khớp cái này sôi tên gần giống
cái này bạn với ai này các thư sự nó
ngôn ngữ nào đấy nhóm cái vân vân để mà
tìm kiếm chính xác một người đó còn bây
giờ thằng Facebook nó chị có cơ chế Kiều
Tìm kiếm mức tương đối rõ Mình thấy có
sự cực khổ trước là mình nhớ tìm kiếm
một bạn nó ra Rất là chọn luôn cảm về
tìm kiếm bạn rõ ràng là mình theo dõi
người ta còn chả ra được người đấy Buồn
vãi
à à
Ừ cái cũng là để mà trình sự Cookie và
cái này có thể xuất Cookie ra đời mà ông
ông có thể đưa Cookie đấy cho người khác
đăng nhập vào hai hàng cũng chung tài
khoản vip thế
Ngon phết này của anh Tuấn đây cái chứ
tinh soket là xong mày không biết rồi
Ừ cái này liên quan đến việc cả em xem
file Vision cái này sao lại về sau các
bạn học để cố tình đi cập được
Ừ cái này cũng hay Cái này là kiểu xem
được video dạng picture-in-picture nghĩa
là video mà sẽ trôi nổi lên à
Ừ cái cổng trời ở công cụ tại ảnh này
Ừ cái này để cốt này xe để lưu lại một
cái gì đó lên facebook bình thường anh
dùng cái thanh tìm không biết các bạn
nha Nhưng mình lưu nhiều lắm nhưng không
phải lưu ý mỗi máy mình lưu lại trên
thanh tranh trên thành này kết hợp việc
lưu luận trên Facebook rất nhiều ạ
Ừ cái để quay video lại màn hình đỡ phải
cài thêm cái phần mềm gì đó và cái này
thực ra mình thấy ngon hơn cả Windows và
Windows
Windows thì nó cũng để quay màn hình ấy
cho mình thế không ngon bằng
à mà nhanh các bạn đỡ phải mất công cài
hơn của phần mềm thứ ba nào đó
Ừ cái nhớ không lầm nóng tương tự
Ừ cái này cái này mình em dụng rất nhiều
bởi vì mình dùng con chuột nhiều hơn bàn
phím khi mà lớn ướt thì vì sẽ dùng cái
tiện ích này về mặt nhảy lên đầu nhưng
súng cuối cùng một trang web nhanh Anh
Ừ cái kiểu như thế
Ừ
cái này để cho các bạn copy Ở một trang
nào đó mà không cho phép copy này thường
là cái này nó Chị Liên quan việc là sự
dung ra chút ít về chặn chạm copy thôi
còn nếu mà nó can thiệp bằng nó chèn
thêm một cái đít quảng cáo
ở phòng lũ nữa mới đít một cái đít nó nó
bác ra ở trong suốt đấy để mà các bạn
không bấm được vào chữ ấy thì các bạn
phải ấn F12 vậy mà xóa cái đoạn đi về đi
nhá chứ tí hay không có ứng dụng được
cái đấy
Ừ cái này ra một trong những cái mà mình
cảm thấy rất phù hợp cho mình và ngon
vãi Cái này nó là gì Hồi đấy mình tìm
kiếm
ý mình muốn tìm kiếm hay cảm nha là sở
là mình đang chơi lỡ lời mình ngại thoát
ra ngoài để mà chỉnh lại nhạc
ở trên bàn phím của mình không có cái
nút kiểu mấy ông biết có một vài bàn
phím nó sẽ gắn nút là chuyển bài nữa là
nút power có sự thử bàn phím tôi không
có cái đấy
Ừ thì mày ông sẽ phải làm nhà mày không
sẽ phải Tab ra ngoài để chuyển nhạc
không ạ Không mày kể những cái phím tắt
đấy thì cái thằng này nó hỗ trợ này em
với ông tạo chúng ta cũng không những là
chuyển được nhạc mấy ông còn chuyện được
video ở trên YouTube nữa cho mấy bạn nào
thích nghe nhạc trên YouTube
xe tải tôi bảo tôi lười nhưng tôi ngồi
mò Tìm mấy cái mày thấy tiện ích tắt
thích vết cái size US này
bản thân cái silas này nó đã rất ngon
được gọi là cái tiện ích này hỗ trợ
để chỉnh CS của tất cả đã sang mà các
bạn muốn và về thư viện cái to cái cửa
hàng của nói không phải cửa hàng chính
xác là cái store kiểu nó trong bán thì
là trên đấy mà ông ông thích thể tải về
này Tôi cho ông xem qua
các
exon đã
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ tao nó bay rồi nhớ nó có sau đấy thật
để tính mở nó lên à
em tắt cái của mình ở beta
ở tại khái nó có một cái store để mà Mấy
ông để tải về
à à Suốt cốt video
Ừ nếu có thể tải về những cái kiểu những
cái dao những cái CS kiểu giao diện đã
đục chỉnh bởi người khác người khác sẽ
chia sẻ cái đoạn cs7 cho ông để ông thể
tải về nhanh để đón đấy trình được bao
nhiêu người làm giao diện đẹp mắt kiểu
có lấy mình có dùng Mà có dùng của trong
chính của trong thành viên ở trong như
tim từng chia sẻ luôn đó diện Facebook
đẹp kinh khủng nhờ đương nhiên đấy giao
diện Facebook cũ bây giờ mới nó đổi rồi
nhưng mà
trên to người ta người ta sẽ đăng bao
nhiêu CS để đấy giống như củ cải trắng
cốt em trước đi mấy ông rồi đó copy về
đây không tự biến với giao diện Facebook
hoặc hoặc là giao diện bất kỳ của sông
Lung Linh không ạ sung người khác nhìn
vào người ta đánh giá ngày ngầu thấy
hack Facebook có thứ gì em
tắt group cái này để lưu lại nhiều Tab
của ông vào cùng 1 thư mục là sự là ông
thấy ở đây có nhiều tác quá là sự như
của anh Mạnh Tuấn tôi toàn xem anh ấy
phải hơn hai mươi ba mươi mấy cái Tab ở
đây này thì thì cài cái tiện ích này
nhóm toàn bộ cái Tab đấy vào trong thư
mục học tập ngay toàn bộ áp khác là tôi
một tài trí hành hạ bằng chứng Anh
Ừ cái để chỉnh sửa về thay địa chỉ ngang
này thôi nghĩa mấy ông Dân lập trình
kiểu hình nên biết mày cứ thích này
tiện ích này hôm đấy mình cài để mà sẽ
bóng đá bởi vì thấy trang web này nó
tiếng có bé quá trình cài tiện ích này
và tăng đường lên tận năm trăm phần trăm
nữa vì thế không biết đúng hay không
nhưng mà tĩnh này khuyên là mấy ông 100
trận mất bác sĩ và mấy ông ngồi lên cài
rồi Thôi vậy không thì
cho nó dễ làm hỏng loa cũng sớm
Ừ thế này để mà lập trình review này tx
này để đo thời gian của ông sử dụng cái
gì nghe liên quan đến cốt nhé sử dụng
code các thứ thử nha Cái này cũng đã để
cốt lập trình web này cũng là lập trình
web này lập trình này lập trình này đây
tôi có bạn thì của tôi nhiều lập chính
mai hết Không có gì bậy bạ rồi
đấy thôi Có ai có nhược điểm này nữa tôi
khuyên mấy ông làm mấy ông máy cấu hình
yếu rồi mày ông tắt bớt tiện ích Tắt bớt
không cần phải xóa đi để cho khi mà lướt
cái gì đó nó bị đấu bị ngốn bởi vì cái
này Ừ cái này nó động nghĩa việc là các
bạn mở bao nhiêu cái diện tích là khi
các bạn và một trang bất kỳ khi nó sẽ
loát 7 nhiều cái file Swift và cái đống
này lên đến 900 đấy hết thành ra là
Trang đấy tự nhiên nó phải ra rất là
nặng
cho dù rõ ràng là Trang đấy nó chẳng làm
gì cả Sao ăn gì có tội đấy tự nhiên là
do người ông cài mới ông diện tích sâu
rồi cùng khiến tranh ấy lót trận bé hội
chửi bọn nó đồ Ngoan thì mới ông nên tắt
bớt nhưng không Nếu không dùng tôi phải
tắt bớt đây lâu lắm rồi không quên không
và nhờ tôi cậy máy tôi ra khỏe không ạ
Nên tôi cứ mở lên thôi
ừ ừ
à à
cô bạn kia nói chọn thể để mà ra Pixel
thì đưa tiện ích đấy rule rồi mà Google
Adsense I
ở các lỗi lo này thì phải
ở đó
a VPN VPN được không nắm rõ về cái video
lắm gần đây mình tiếp cận nọ mình có
nghe nói nhiều nhưng mà gần hết mình mấy
cái dùng nó thường xuyên
Ừ ừ Mình mình à Đây để nó qua cái VPN và
nói chung về cái mạng ấy thứ ba gần đây
mình đang thấy phải trang rất là hay
chia sẻ trên nhóm mình rồi nó trang cứt
Kỳ Hân Hoan này bông Tôi khuyên mày ông
nên theo dõi cho ngày anh Bởi vì trang
này nó nó đang rất nhiều về không phải
về lập trình mà về bên kiến thức mạnh
như kiến thức này
mô hình giới thiệu cách nói rất là dễ
hiểu
chị sẽ là 2
trọn bộ kiến thức mạng và trong này có
cả Liên quan mấy cái ví dụ là kiểu khách
khùng như thế nào bản chất cái thuật ngữ
đấy là gì Phân vân đấy
số trang anh Trang người Việt nữa thứ
thứ đúng ạ
ở nhóm lên thử đọc một vài bài đây Tôi
tin là mấy ông lưu lại một đống bài luôn
không Hôm qua tôi mới ngồi lướt tiếp
phải mất công lưu lại tiền mà đọc lại
thì gặp lại cho hiểu lệ thấm nếu mà nó
rất là hay
anh em ơi ông thế đấy xem
ở bờ
hôm nay lại chuẩn bị lại quá thời gian
rồi nó trả không còn gì nhỉ à
Ê mấy ông xã ăn tối đi Tôi vừa ăn trưa
đây Chào mấy ông nhé
Hi Chào mọi người ạ